[Musique]
la grosse
lan na na nana na na
na na la jungle
[Musique]
oui mais j'ai le téléphone pire je
téléphone de poutine donald trump ces
gens là n'ont de frappe aux 18 noms on
sait jamais il veut te répondre tu veux
vous dire que votre homme odieux
berlusconi s'il répond c'est toi qui se
doit qui part d'un voile à tf1 je vous
dis ah super répond pas mais je vous
garantis que monsieur poutine et
monsieur trump ils écoutent nos
conversations
pour m'a proposé de faire de la danse
classique ici à l'opéra de paris le
problème j'ai dû choisir un certain
moment entre les arts martiaux et la
danse classique parce que les bras
devenait norme lte où et quand tu fais
des pâtes 2 est un des gros des gros
triceps cécilia soit 1 et à certains
moments il faut il faut décider
l'intersection où tu vas soit les arts
martiaux où la danse classique et j'ai
continué donc dans les arbres sur
non j'ai choisi ce nom parce que il y
avait un homme assez âgé et son nom
c'était paul van damme c'est un copain à
moi et il adorait la boxe j'avais quoi
jamais 17 18 ans et jeudi paul je vais
réussir
dans le sport
champion du monde dans le cinéma et mali
puis sera un grand acteur jeudi me coûte
si jamais je réussis dans le monde du
cinéma je prendrai ton nom en l'honneur
donc annoncé bon varembert
[Musique]
impossible
ce serait bien je serai
serait ça serait sympa comme tout le
monde le ferait alors hein t'imagines tu
te faut opérer pour le grand écart dans
la dgrad l'écart
non c'est pas vrai j'ai failli me battre
oui mais c'est parfait ça c'est
malheureusement pas faire un truc
d'enfants quoi je n'ai pas bien ce qu'il
a dit et voilà et je t'attends d'or il
n'est pas sorti surtout
j'ai attendu longtemps
c'était juste un autre en plus ton est à
miami
mais c'est un truc de gosse
maintenant j'ai j'ai passé la
cinquantaine
[Musique]
non
non mais je les écoute de la musique je
peux te répéter mais mais c'est super
comme suit en soit
il change son music
group
[Musique]
la nana na na
nana na na
pas mon corps
mais ses paroles sur un peu brun sombre
parce qu'il dit
mais je dis ce que je dis je m'en fous
tout le monde je dis ce que je pense
quoi
la philosophie à des étages différents
tons à chacun sa propre philosophie donc
tu as ta philosophie on a tous une
philosophie donc je suis vraiment
passionnée de ma philosophie est de
votre philosophie ouais de 9,2 vie
[Musique]
comme j'étais un peu dans mon univers à
moi et mon père avait une librairie
c'était dans l'univers des dessins
animés bon tintin spirou les schtroumpfs
astérix obélix tout ça
beaucoup de dessins animés et
c'est un garçon à l'école j'étais pas
seulement très sociable
mort dans l'âme à ma propre bulle toi et
je me suis un peu réfugier dans les
aventures du dessin animé ça m'a dit ça
m'a aidé à réussir à croire que tout est
possible
[Musique]
jamais être à l'heure je suis toujours
lors d'art dans les rendez vous et tout
ça mais sur un tournage le chialeux
[Musique]
yayi
oui bientôt
sont minimes on donnera des cours de
souplesse et comme on est le maintien et
tout ça et ça sera bien fait il y aura
de belles lumières pas si tu as des
suggestions marqué sur un papier je les
prendrai
non c'est faux c'est faux c'est que
j'aime quelqu'un parce que c'est
chimique pleurer tu peux pas tu ne peut
pas stopper les larmes c'est pas
possible ça dépend aussi de tous niveaux
de sensibilité et des gens qui sont plus
sensibles que d'autres et des gens qui
sont moins sensibles que d'autres il ya
des gens qui sont plus forts dans la
politique et des gens qui seront plus
forts dans la peinture dans la musique
on a chacun ses qualités quoi je suis un
garçon très sensible donc je peux
pleurer
faux je n'ai pas menti dans cette
émission
d'ailleurs moi je mange à rien
[Musique]